Joe Biden fails to make the case for his
own candidacy half of young voters think
the world will end in the decade and the
left ignores actual scientists 500 of
them on global warming all of which
reveals an eternal and important and
urgent truth about politics lies come
with a great cost we will examine the
price of Lies in politics then President
Trump defends America at the UN the
Ukraine scandal implicates not just Joe
Biden but other Democrats as well and
Michelle Williams whoever that is
spreads nonsense at the Emmy Awards all
that and more I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
boy oh boy do we have a lot to get to
today first though I've got to thank our
wonderful sponsors over at NetSuite
listen one of the biggest most difficult
challenges that businesses encounter
when they're starting up is that you
can't keep track of anything the problem
growing businesses have that keeps them
from knowing their numbers is they've
got this hodgepodge of business systems
and that is where NetSuite comes in very
handy I've been involved in a lot of
start-up businesses over the years
including obviously this one and this is
always the case you go in and you say
okay I'm going to use this this software
for this aspect of my business and I'm
going to use this for this and I'm gonna
use that for that and then they're not
talking to each other you can't keep
track of things and then time is money
introducing that suite by Oracle the
business management software that
handles every aspect of your business in
an easy-to-use cloud platform giving you
the visibility and control you need to
grow with NetSuite you save time money
and unneeded headaches by managing sales
you can manage finance you manage
accounting you manage orders you manage
HR instantly right from your desktop or
phone that is why NetSuite is the
world's number one cloud business system
looking back I wish it had occurred to
us I wish this were available when I was
starting other businesses because you
just do it really quickly to begin with
and then it causes headaches down the
road NetSuite is the way to go right now
in NetSuite it's offering you valuable
insights with a free guide seven key
strategies to grow your profits at
NetSuite comm slash Knowles canna wles
that's NetSuite comm slash Knowles
Kanter wles to download your free guide
seven key strategies to grow your
profits NetSuite dot-com slash Knowles
Kanter wles
a lot of news to get to today first bit
of news I want to get to is in the 2020
race because that is what is dominating
our politics right now and Joe Biden who
is dominating the Democratic field keeps
failing and failing and failing and
people are blaming a lot of different
aspects of Biden's candidacy for why
it's falling apart his age his teeth his
plastic surgery is
is all of these things his 1994 crime
bill his career there trying to blame
all of these things I think it comes
down to one character flaw
above all he doesn't believe in anything
and he has no regard for the truth and
this is a problem that affects a lot of
our politics today here's Joe Biden he's
being asked on camera why people should
elect him president he doesn't have an
answer well and I want the unemployment
rate is two and a half percent people
say they are employed in Iowa and their
small businesses are growing Iowa rose
from before he they're employed before
he got elected the president won by 10
percentage points and I'm not suggest he
didn't win my 10 percentage points well
I'm suggesting this he's not the reason
for that employment rate being down but
why he don't want to make a change
though well that's up to them to decide
why should they for them to decide will
make your case I'm not going I'm not
going to make the case because I can't
make the case Biden makes two big
mistakes here he has two major failings
he can't make the case for himself and
he hasn't been able to make the case for
himself at all I mean he launched his
campaign his campaign ad against Trump
he basically said Trump is a big racist
so vote for me and then he took Trump's
charlottesville comments out of context
he cut out the spot where he explicitly
condemned neo-nazis and white
supremacists and he said see Donald
Trump likes neo-nazis and white
supremacist that's all he did in his
initial campaign ad for 2020 that's the
first problem he can't make the case for
himself he's just saying Trump is a bad
guy
the second problem a related problem is
he can't actually make the case against
Trump and this reporter who was
interviewing him nails him on it she
says look the economy's going well
life is good people are generally happy
with the way things are going why would
people vote for you and he says well
Trump's not responsible for any of that
it's all actually someone else's
responsibility and Trump didn't do any
of that and she has the correct
follow-up which is okay maybe that's
true may
the great economy that we're living
under right now in the Trump
administration maybe that's not thanks
to Trump maybe that's thanks to Obama
Bush or Bill Clinton or Calvin Coolidge
whoever it's is actually responsible for
it things are going well right now why
would voters want to change and his
answer is astounding he says well yeah
the voters have to make that decision
the question wasn't who makes the
decision about whether or not to change
because the correct answer to that
question would be the voters make the
decision the question was why should
people change not who but why he doesn't
know and she gives him another at-bat
she says okay you've kind of missed that
one but can you tell us of course the
voters are gonna make the decision but
why should the voters make the decision
to change now he says well they have to
make that decision I don't I'm not gonna
make the case because you don't have a
case to make this is where it would help
if Joe Biden believed in anything this
is where it would help if Joe Biden had
any regard for the truth if you have
regard for the truth if you state plain
truth you're gonna have angry mobs come
after you especially in politics that's
what politics is that's what politics
always has been
you might remember at the University of
Missouri Kansas City I was physically
attacked because I said men are not
women I gave a speech there a few months
ago
the statement I made was men are not
women very difficult to disagree with
that you could say the sky is blue you
could say two plus two equals four and
there was a mob of people screaming at
me from the minute I opened my mouth I
didn't let them shut me up
they stormed out some guy comes in and
assaults me with some creepy strange
super soaker that's the price of telling
the truth in politics if you say the
world won't end in 12 years if you say
we shouldn't kill our babies if you say
we shouldn't put little children on
puberty blockers when they're three
years old and and permanently change
their biology if you exploit children in
any way you're gonna have people come
after you that's just the way it is
if you are going to have to take slings
and arrows for standing up for the truth
that's that's the way politics goes
however it's not all bad news because in
the long run the truth is all you've got
and the great statesmen of history are
the ones who stood firm and spoke the
truth and didn't cower to mobs Joe Biden
ain't that statesman okay he's never
been that statesman I'm not even saying
it's necessarily a left-right thing or a
republican-democrat thing but it is
certainly the case that Joe Biden does
not rise to that level Joe Biden has no
regard for the truth he has taken the
easy way out in politics again and again
his whole life and now it's coming back
to haunt him because now he's up for the
big office and he's got the best chance
that he's ever had of getting that big
office and it's absolutely hilarious cuz
he doesn't know what to say the guy ran
in 88 he got thrown out of the race for
being a liar and a plagiarist he runs in
2008 he was nothing nobody cared about
that candidacy he only became the vice
president because Barack Obama hates
Hillary Clinton so much he couldn't bear
the thought of her being his vice
president then he runs in 2020 and he
actually is the leader of the pack but
what's he gonna run on politics has
changed so much and he has always moved
with the wind in politics but he's been
in it so long 50 years that it looks
absurd for Joe Biden to try to put on
the pink hat and look as woke as can be
when people know he hasn't been saying
those things for his whole career that
the most hilarious version of this was
when he was just recently asked his
opinion on gender identity and sexuality
in prisons so specifically the question
is right now there is a cultural
movement an ideological movement to
redefine sex to gender so sex is pretty
clear you're a man or a woman a very
very small number of people have
ambiguous genitalia and another very
small number of people though an
increasing number of people suffer from
something called gender confusion or
gender dysphoria but there are two sexes
male and female
man and woman we have a lot of
legislation based on these sexist so for
instance the title nine legislation says
you won't discriminate on the basis of
sex
you you've set up sports leagues for
instance for women because women are
physically not as strong as men and so
women get their own sports leagues by
redefining sex into gender you
obliterate those sexual protections so
if you redefine sex as gender all of a
sudden the women's sports league ceases
to exist because men who identify as
women are allowed to participate in the
women's sports league and guess what
they're gonna win statistically all of
the time
why because men and women are physically
different and men are physically
stronger than women that was the point
of the legislation in the first place so
now this kind of legislation this kind
of ideologies is reaching into the
prisons what biden was asked was do you
think that men who identify as women who
are convicts who are going to prison
should be housed in prison with women
should a guy six-foot to 240 pounds
double murderer
real tough scary guy if he puts on a
dress and a wig frankly even if he
doesn't but he identifies as a woman
should he be housed in prisons with
women what could go wrong right what
could possibly go wrong obviously this
is a horrible idea
it puts these women who are in prison in
incredible danger more danger than
they're already in being in prison but
because Joe Biden doesn't actually
believe in anything because he has no
regard for the truth because he's
willing to tell whatever sort of lies
the mob wants him to tell he goes along
with this and he endorses putting male
convicts in the female prison in prison
the determination should be that your
sexual identity is defined by what you
say it is not what in fact the prison
says it is and in that case you should
be entitled also to OGB Wang anyway you
didn't ask that question which was not
likely to either I guess so I love he
does the Biden thing which is he he
doesn't understand this issue at all he
obviously doesn't frankly no one
understands this issue because they keep
changing it every day on gender ideology
so he says ok my advisers told me yeah
the identity of the gender that's you
got to do that and so then the men
to go to the anyway I never know never
never mind and he always runs out of
steam because first of all the things
he's saying or ridiculous and even Joe
Biden realizes that they're going toward
illogical ends but also because he
doesn't really believe it and he didn't
really believe the thing he thought
before he didn't really believe the
thing he thought before that this is
obviously ridiculous but what does it
mean what does it mean for that eternal
truth that allies have a price we'll get
to that in a second first I have to
thank our friends over at Lending Club
credit card debt can be very very
dangerous it is very easy to accumulate
lots of credit card debt because you
just go you go in you buy it now you pay
for it later everything will be fine but
look we can never predict the future
maybe you'll lose a job maybe you won't
have opportunities to to pay for that
you don't want to get bogged down with
that credit card companies rope you in
and they leave out the part about paying
later with interest with Lending Club
you can consolidate your debt or pay off
credit cards with one fixed monthly
payment Lending Club has helped millions
of people regain control of their
finances with affordable fixed-rate
personal loans no trips to the bank this
is very important for me as a millennial
is I never want to leave my couch no
high interest credit cards just go to
Lending Club com tell them about
yourself tell them how much you want to
borrow pick the terms that are right for
you
if you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
account
in as little as a few days Lending Club
is the number one peer-to-peer lending
platform with over thirty five billion
dollars in loans issued don't get into
this awful credit card debt don't
unnecessarily throw your money at the
credit card companies because you're
paying high interest rates doesn't have
to be so hard to get out of debt with
Lending Club go to Lending Club com /
Knolls
KO wles check your eight minutes borrow
up to $40,000 that is Lending Club com /
Knolls Lending Club com / Knolls all
loans made by web bank member FDIC Equal
Housing lender so Biden's statement is
obviously ridiculous but it shows you
that difference what great statesmen do
what significant political figures do is
they stand up for the truth and they
stand up for the vulnerable and what
hacks do is it
don't even so much always contradict the
truth as they just ignore it the
greatest example of this the greatest
example of a cynic in history is Pontius
Pilate Pontius Pilate when he's talking
to Christ Christ says I come to bear
witness to the truth and Pilate doesn't
say no you don't or he doesn't say
you're a liar he doesn't do that what he
says is more damning he says what is
truth
shrugs his shoulders walks away it's
that flippancy
that makes you a cynic and that's what
Joe Biden is that's been his career and
now he's paying the price for that he's
paying the price not even for his active
lies but for his acquiescence to lies is
indifference for lies and his
indifference for the truth lies have a
price lies can whip people up into a
frenzy there is a new poll from
Rasmussen you know everyone's been
talking about climate change all week
because there were all these crazy
climate change religious rituals going
on over the weekend and strange people
dancing and all sorts of bizarre
activities there's a new Rasmussen poll
out more than half of young voters
believe that humanity will be wiped out
within a decade or so that is an
astounding number over it's even even a
little crazy when you look at the whole
voting population this survey found that
over the next 10 to 15 years 29% of all
voters of all voters believe it is at
least somewhat likely that the earth
will become uninhabitable and humanity
will be wiped out nearly 30% of all
voters think that within 10 to 15 years
humanity will be wiped out why do they
think that because cynical politicians
and exploitative politicians go out
there and they tell us this all the time
I mean they've been telling us this
since the 1970s and for some reason
they're incorrect predictions never seem
to matter they just go back to the next
day and make more incorrect predictions
but we've been told by aoc very famously
that the world is going to end in 12
years we were then told by beta will
work
is going to end in ten years we were
then told by the UK's Prince Charles a
whole slew of predictions could be 35
years could be 35 months could be 14
months could be they keep moving the
goal posts AOC just said that Miami is
going to be under water within two years
why are they saying this are they saying
this because they think it's true I
don't think so
I don't I don't think that they really
believe that if they did if they really
believed that probably AOC would move
out of New York I mean that's pretty low
area it's pretty close to the waters
probably move a little more inland if
they really believed that we were on the
brink of extinction the UK's Prince
Harry who had been posting all over
social media about how we must protect
the environment this is the most
important issue of the day it then came
out he flew on a private jet four times
in 11 days if they really were concerned
about this they would do something much
more than this kind of shallow virtue
signaling and this fear mongering I
suspect what this is really about is
they don't know if the world is going to
end in I don't know three or four
hundred years or if it's going to end at
all they really have no idea when it's
gonna end but I don't actually don't
think they care I don't think it's about
that at all I think they see climate
change as a very useful way of getting
coincidentally all of the policies that
the left is wanted for a hundred years
pushed through legislatures and pushed
through the international community and
so they're just gonna say it not because
they think it's true not because they
think it's wrong just because they're
cynics just because it helps them it's
politically convenient there's a cost to
this if you now have 51% of voters under
35 who believe that it is at least
somewhat likely that humanity will be
wiped out in the next decade or so
something has gone horribly wrong that
is really detrimental to society that is
really an awful thing to do to whip up
half of the young population
particularly young people who are
particularly vulnerable to whip them up
into a frenzy of anxiety and stress
and despair because they think that
humanity is going to be wiped off the
earth in a decade just so that you can
raise taxes just so that you can get a
little more control over industry just
so that you can transfer wealth from one
group of people you don't like to a
group of people that you do like it's
disgusting it's awful to do that
that's what cynics do I don't think
history will look very kindly on those
people but they do a great job of
whipping up the mob and ironically it's
the mob who are who are being exploited
here this tells you if you've got half
people or more than half of young voters
who's thinking that humanity will be
wiped off the face of the earth within
ten years it shows you that climate
change increasingly and finally has
ceased to be scientific it just isn't a
scientific matter at all if it were half
of young voters wouldn't think that
humanity is on the verge of extinction
so climate change as we've been talking
about all week is a religious movement
that much is clear
we've seen the carbon indulgences you
can buy a carbon offset just like in the
medieval church you could purchase
indulgences for your sins we've seen the
public rituals we saw on NBC News a
climate confessional where you can go in
and confess you're polluting sins to the
climate priests at MSNBC or NBC rather
obviously this irritates the Protestant
environmentalists who want to just
confess directly to Mother Earth over
the past several days we've seen a
funeral for a glacier I don't know how
you have a funeral for a glacier I
assume you don't have a cremation but
you have a funeral somehow we saw that
in Switzerland now we have a proposal in
Bloomberg for a ritual called meatless
Mondays the guy writing in Bloomberg
suggested this the idea has been floated
around for a while and the ideas you can
eat meat every day the week but you
can't eat meat on Mondays now this is
ironic because there was a study in 2015
that came out of Carnegie Mellon
University which suggested that meatless
diets are actually worse for the
environment than diets with meat and
American diets have a lot of meat in it
they found that the meatless diets
actually result in more carbon emissions
they result in a larger water footprint
they
result in greater energy use so this is
kind of funny I always loved these
ironies of the Beatle activists who are
so insistent that we follow one policy
that actually is counterproductive to
their named goal but that really isn't
their goal and the science of it doesn't
matter and it doesn't matter whether
meatless Mondays help the environment or
hurt the environment because the point
of meatless Monday's the point of the
whole thing is not to help the
environment the point is to fulfill a
religious longing I'm Catholic I abstain
from meat on Fridays at least when I
remember that's a religious discipline I
like it if I were a leftist or an
environmentalist I would abstain from
meat on Mondays because that's the day
they've chosen to fulfill their
religious disciplines it's actually kind
of funny how directly analogous the
environmentalist movement has become to
the Catholic Church specifically you've
got the confessionals you've got the
indulgences you've got the abstaining
from meat on one day of the week I think
some conservatives are approaching this
issue in the wrong way though I think a
lot of conservatives are saying because
I think now pretty much we all agree
climate change has ceased to be
scientific when you spend all of your
time convincing half of young voters
that the world is going to end in ten
years you are no longer scientific
you've moved into the realm of something
else something a little more cultish but
what conservatives are now saying at
least some of them is they're saying
climate change is a religion as though
that discredits it but I don't think it
discredits it I think actually there's
quite a lot to be said here and there's
actually a productive conclusion from
the idea that climate change is a
religion we'll get to that in a second
but first I have got to thank our
friends over at Vistaprint your next
opportunity might be coming right now
and vistaprint is here to help you own
the now with free shipping on any
business card in any quantity you know
it's very important you never know what
is going to happen in the future
sometimes you've got a guy who's about
to offer you a job and you don't have
your business card sometimes you lose a
job and you got to meet a guy who's
gonna offer you a job and then you hand
them your business card but a lot of
times I don't have business cards on me
because I'm irresponsible
so I have used
to print for at this point probably
eight or nine years I have when I have
been responsible enough to order
business cards they have always been
unbelievably reliable they have been
there they're just the best in the
business you can choose whatever style
finish shape or paper you like and get
free shipping because you can pick the
colors fonts designs and images it means
you can create something as unique and
compelling is your business business
cards are really important don't be like
irresponsible teenage me get your
business cards if you're ready to get
started on your business card is very
easy you plug in your information and
logo into hundreds of fresh designs
tailored to your type of company or you
upload your original layout then you
pick the paper stock
I like the linen one I don't know call
me extra call me fancy I don't know what
to tell you I like the linen one I
choose the style choose the quantity
that's right for you you can even
upgrade to a unique touch like rounded
corners order and receive your cards
with free economy shipping these guys
are so great to work with that's why
I've worked with them since long before
the daily wire existed as if you needed
any more reasons to choose Vistaprint
you can now feel good knowing this to
print uses only carefully selected inks
and responsibly sourced paper stocks
satisfaction is 100% guaranteed or your
money back they will make it right they
always do Vista Print wants you to be
able to own the now in any situation
which is why listeners will get free
shipping on all business cards any style
any quantity go to vistaprint.com enter
promo code Noles
- that's knowles kinder wles and the
number - i guess they have beyonce as a
client as well you'll get free shipping
on all business cards any style any
quantity limited time offer own the now
at vistaprint.com promote knowles - that
is promo code knowles followed by the
number two you support our show when you
support our sponsors and we really
appreciate that a lot of conservatives
are saying global warming is a religion
as if that somehow discredits it I don't
think so I think it actually speaks
pretty well of global warming or it at
least speaks to a genuine longing in a
leftists which is human beings are
religious creatures it was Thomas
Aquinas who wrote that or I don't know
one of those really smart old religious
guys human beings are religious
creatures we have a natural
for religion for the divine for God it
is just built into us that's why every
single civilization everywhere in the
world has had religion and religions
that are actually somewhat recognizable
to one another
climate change is religion for the left
it's religion for atheists people who
have increasingly abandoned religion
over the past four or five six decades
and so they're channeling it into global
warming they've got their own apocalypse
which is apparently going to happen in
ten years in wipe humanity off the earth
I don't know what that rapture is going
to look like they've got their own
sacraments they've got their own
disciplines they've and by the way the
minute you point this out the minute you
criticize their cult they lose it they
go crazy they've got their own secular
Saints and they will really come after
you not with the cool reasoned balanced
approach of people discussing ideas but
they will come after you viciously and
violently like cultists I don't even say
this to denigrate them the challenge for
conservatives is not to make fun of them
for being cultists the challenge for
conservatives is to take and persuade
the left's natural religious longings
and turn it back toward true religion
toward I think actually this is what a
lot of the white privilege stuff is
about I think when you talk about white
guilt white privilege skin privilege all
the identity politics it's all based on
physical characteristics I just watched
Chelsea Handler's horrific documentary
on privilege and she left an event where
people were yelling at her for being
white and she said I liked it I liked
that they put me in my place again we
could make fun of her for that I'm sure
there's a lot of psychology there but it
actually speaks to a human longing we
want to be put in our place in a way
because we all Intuit our own brokenness
our own fallenness our own imperfect
nature and the way that this would
traditionally be discussed is in the
language of original sin or broken human
nature or imperfect ability but because
the left now denies metaphysical reality
because they deny any spiritual
component to our lives and they think
we're all just a clump of cells and big
meat puppets moving around in a
materialist universe they can't trace
their feelings of imperfection the
anxiety that comes from their fallenness
and original sin they can't trace it
metaphysically it has to become physical
it has to be your skin color or your sex
or your genitals or whatever the
religion has to become a physical
religion that is focused on the creature
the creation the earth itself rather
than the Creator in the metaphysical and
spiritual world that's a major
difference it is a natural consequence
of atheism because everybody's got to
serve somebody it's a natural
consequence of materialism our challenge
is to pull that back our challenge is to
turn the left not just to mock them but
to turn them back toward a more
sophisticated and a truer metaphysical
reality some people wonder why climate
change relates so directly to leftism
beyond just this you know religious
aspect beyond the metaphysical aspect
it's because the effect of climate
change hysteria is just coincidentally
to give everything to the left that
they've wanted for 100 years George will
famously called it socialism by the
backdoor the term they use a science
denier it's the same sort of term that
now they're applying to us because of
global warming science but this is the
same term the left applied to their
opponents who opposed communism or
socialism for a century because the idea
of Marxism and communism and socialism
is that the left had figured out the
science of history you hear Herbert
Marcuse I talk about this other writers
of the new left the old left - they'd
figured out the science of history and
so if you opposed that you were a
science denier you had American
journalists go over to the Soviet Union
and say I've seen the future and it
works that history was just going to be
on the scientific progression that's why
Bill Buckley when he started the
National Review said a conservative is
one who stands that's word history
yelling stop they've been calling a
science deniers forever that's built in
to their own ideology we've got to break
that there's nothing new I mean there's
not really a new challenge even the way
they come after you like a mob there's
nothing really new about that either
you've got to stand firm and
we're getting great news out of the
White House which I guess is actually at
at the UN which if I have my way some
day will be the Trump condominiums on
the East River President Trump went over
to the UN yesterday and he did just that
he stood athwart this intersection of
the climate ideology and the leftist
politics which are really the same thing
he stood have worded in no uncertain
terms it was an excellent performance
we'll get to that in a second we will
get to what scientists have to say about
global warming and we'll get to a whole
lot more but first I've got to say
goodbye to Facebook and YouTube if you
were on Facebook and YouTube go on over
to daily wire daily wired.com ten bucks
a month $100 for an annual membership
you get me you get the Andrew Clavin
show you get the Ben Shapiro sure you
get the mount wall sure you get to ask
questions in the mailbag that's coming
up on Thursday you get to ask questions
backstage you get another Kingdom which
is really superb and you get the leftist
tears tumblr leftist here's tumblr very
important you know the left gets very
disappointed these days they thought
they had a good candidate they were
gonna take Trump out of the White House
they think they can take certain
conservative figures out of the public
sphere and then they can't and then the
tears flow that's a much bigger tidal
wave than global warming and you're only
one of them is going to drown you so
make sure you get your left is tears
tumblr so that you stay nice and safe
head to Daley wire comm we'll be right
back with a lot more
President Trump went to the UN yesterday
and he tackled this issue head-on
because what the left wants you to
believe is that there is a scientific
consensus as though science were made by
consensus that the world is going to end
in ten years nobody thinks that no
scientist not one actual scientist
thinks that the human race will be
extinct in ten years even though that's
what politicians are selling us even
though that's what half of young voters
apparently believe totally unscientific
but what they the left wants you to
think is that climate change is the
scientific issue look it's just the
science no politics involved and hey
coincidentally because of that science
you need to give us higher taxes the
redistribution of wealth reparations for
slavery for some reason that's and
that's in a lot of the green new deal
like proposals not sure why but it is
you need to give us open borders you
need to give us greater international
control of government you need to
surrender some of your sovereignty you
need to surrender some of your power
when it comes to negotiating trade deals
you need to do all of this because of
the science you said what does any of
that have to do with science I don't see
they say no no you just have to that's
the natural progression and so the UN is
a great place to do this this is why the
UN has led the way talking about global
warming
it's just coincidentally the global
warming alarmism achieves all of the
UN's goals for a very long time so
President Trump goes to the UN and he's
not fooled by this false distinction
without a difference he goes at it head
on and he says using one term globalist
he sums it all up and he makes clear the
future does not belong to the globalists
here is the truth is plain to see if you
want freedom take pride in your country
if you want democracy hold on to your
sovereignty and if you want peace love
your nation wise leaders always put the
good of their own people and their own
country first
the future does not belong to globalize
the future belongs to Patriots the
future belongs to sovereign and
independent nations who protect their
citizens respect their neighbors and
honor the differences that make each
country special and unique absolutely
beautiful
spot on you know there's a defeater for
this whole climate change argument to
begin with what we're told by the global
climate change movement is we've got to
stop Trump Trump is destroying the world
that's what some people have said even
on television the Trump is destroying
the world and yet they blame Trump for
pulling out of the Paris climate Accord
they said that's it that's gonna ruin
the whole world year or two after Trump
pulled out of that global climate Accord
they looked at the numbers turned out
the United States not only didn't put
more carbon into the air didn't pollute
more than they had previously the u.s.
actually led the world in reducing their
carbon emissions even as they pulled out
of the global climate Accord and
actually a number of nations including
Western European nations who signed on
to the global climate Accord not only
didn't follow what they agreed to they
actually increased their polluting so
what Trump is saying a system of free
and sovereign nations with
self-government is the best way to have
a good peaceful future I mean that
applies apparently quite literally to
the climate change issue because what is
the opposite of a free and sovereign
nation you've got China China leftism
taken to its logical extreme an actual
communist country leading the world by
many multiples in their pollution we
could all stop polluting tomorrow we
could all just sit and stop breathing
and hold our breath wouldn't do anything
because China has such a
disproportionate effect that's not what
it's about it's not about the
environment what it is about is the
globalism it is the leftism it is you
use whatever term you want to use Trump
sees that and for people who
say Trump is a dolt he doesn't know
anything about politics he doesn't
really know about his opponents he don't
know what he's doing that is a
sophisticated conclusion to reach not a
lot of people understand that
relationship that climate change
hysteria is socialism by the backdoor
not a lot of people have put their
finger on that he has he gets it he's
speaking very bluntly and he's speaking
about protecting the country it's a
beautiful thing that's a real statesman
someone who stands it's worth the mob
stands up for the truth at least in this
regard he has a unique relationship to
the truth when it comes to some personal
matters maybe but when it comes to
matters of actual statecraft and and the
importance of our country he's he's
really risen to the occasion and it's
something to be applauded meanwhile you
got climate scientists actual climate
scientists 500 of them sent a letter
basically begging for an end to all this
cultish Nasir's what the declaration
states climate science should be less
political while climate policies should
be more scientific scientists should
openly address the uncertainties and
exaggerations in their predictions of
global warming while politicians should
dispassionately count the real benefits
as well as the maligned costs of
adaptation to global warming and the
real costs as well as the imagined
benefits of mitigation
they say the importance here the
important thing to do is not rush into
some crazy policy that likely wouldn't
have any effect on the climate anyway
but to understand the facts to let
science pursue scientific inquiry and
not get so mixed up in politics as it
obviously has been because the entire
global warming movement is led by
politicians and the tools of politicians
there is no statistical evidence that
global warming is intensifying
hurricanes they write floods droughts
and such like natural disasters or
making them more frequent
however co2 mitigation measures are as
damaging as they are costly for instance
wind turbines kill birds and bats this
poor guys and palm oil plants destroy
the biodiversity of the rainforests life
is complex is what they're saying
certainly this is true in the most
complex system we have on earth namely
our climate unfortunately no one's
reading this no one pays attention yes
no one cares about the science is all
they care about is the politics and
at the end of that their religion there
is a lot more going on in this Ukraine
scandal just but we'll get to it a
little bit more in depth but what should
be noted there reports out today the
pressure on Ukraine that that Joe Biden
is now in trouble for began as early as
January 2016 when the Obama White House
invited Ukraine's top prosecutors to
Washington to discuss fighting
corruption in the country this is right
around the time that the prosecutors are
looking into Joe Biden's son for all of
his shady and obviously corrupt business
dealings the meeting was sort of a
surprise turned out to be basically just
setting the stage for Biden through the
White House to pressure Ukraine to drop
the inquiry into his son but because of
this meeting this implicates a lot of
other people this implicates the Obama
White House this implicates people
around you Biden this shows this wasn't
just some coincidence and he happened to
be in Ukraine and he said drop it this
was planned this this contradicts a lot
of what Joe Biden has told us it shows
us something very important because you
see first of all you see the Obama White
House colluding with the Ukrainians
whatever that means and then you see a
Biden colluding with the Ukrainians then
they're accusing Trump of colluding with
Ukrainians all this collusion what it
shows you about the left is they accuse
you of doing what they themselves are
doing that's this is an eternal truth of
politics if you are colluding with a
foreign government you accuse your
opponent of colluding with a foreign
government Barack Obama was caught on a
hot mic saying I'll give you a special
deal mr. Medvedev of Russia I'll give
you a special deal but I'm not going to
tell the voters because I'm up for
re-election but I'm gonna give you a
special deal actual collusion on tape
what did they do they spend three years
accusing Trump of colluding with Russia
we have documentary evidence that Joe
Biden and the Obama White House pressure
Ukraine to drop a corruption scandal
into his son what do they do they accuse
Donald Trump of colluding with the
Ukrainians if you're wielding the
government for your political purposes
you accuse your opponent of doing that
very same thing if you are abusing
children you accuse your opponent of
that very same thing it's what the left
does that
the hallmark of what they do and we
should call them out for it we should
expect it it's guaranteed and when they
call it when they get upset because you
call them out for it I think you know
you're above the target we've got to
talk about Michelle Williams in the
culture Michelle Williams is somebody I
guess she's a Hollywood somebody don't
even know her she won an Emmy Award and
she she exposed in a hilarious way the
theme of what we're talking about today
the price of Lies because she's standing
up there holding a glittering gold
statue in the fanciest most glamorous
place on earth
getting awarded for making believe she
used that opportunity to complain about
an imaginary problem when you put value
into a person it empowers that person to
get in touch with their own inherent
value and then where do they put that
value they put it into their work and so
the next time a woman and especially a
woman of color because she stands to
make 52 cents on the dollar compared to
her white male counterpart tells you
what she needs in order to do her job
listen to her that's what it is
I just got this glittering gold statue
for making believe I'm living the dream
all over but I am going to complain
about the so-called wage gap except and
so what she's saying is the wage gap is
bad for men and women but it's
especially bad for white men and women
of color the problem with the wage gap
this this canard that won't go away is
it doesn't exist they have a point in
that there there is a different view
look at the average woman she does make
less money than the average man I
suppose it is the case that if you look
at the average woman of color and the
average white man and the average 50
year-old they average this and the
average that that they are different
numbers but we already knew that because
men and women work different numbers of
hours on average so that was the first
clue that the wage gap isn't really
correct when you control for hours
worked education time in the workforce
expertise on and on and on the wage gap
disappears it virtually vanishes
this is good news you should celebrate
that that's a good thing but instead
they push this lie and there's a cost to
that lie because what the lie tells you
is if you're a woman you can't make it
in America
this lady is on a stage hole during a
glittering gold statue having the job
that little kids dream about having at
the very top of it and her whole speech
was you can't make it someone's gonna
stop you from making it if you're a
woman you can't make it even though I'm
here forget about me ignore me and
especially by the way if you're black
you can't make it no way you can't it's
so awful to tell a little kid that it's
so abusive it's so exploitative to do
that to somebody
to push your political fiction and to
push for your preferred policies whether
that be extra regulations or higher
taxes or whatever before we go today I
don't usually do a stuff I like but I
would like to do a stuff I like because
you know I talk about this all the time
I consider myself very uneducated I I
feel as though there are a lot of books
I should have read when I was a kid I
should have learned some languages I
should I just I feel I think the whole
culture is pretty uneducated but it
really bothers me because I would like
to be educated so I went back recently
and read one of the books that I should
have read probably when I was 10 or 11
classic work 1984 you got to read it
because apparently many other people
I've talked to you haven't read it
either even though it's one that should
be taught in every school and if you
haven't read it in a while
reread it because it tells you a lot
about our culture it describes this
dystopian oppressive environment where
the powers that be control the the words
that you say even the thoughts that you
think and eliminate truth just like
Pontius Pilate there is no truth there
is no right or wrong there is only what
the party says the eternal present where
the party is always right
and it has a lot of parallels to what
we're experiencing today and there's a
lesson at the end of the book I don't
think it's a spoiler alert plus the
books been out for a very long time so
you know if you haven't read it that's
on you
the only way they can break you is if
they can force you to acquiesce to a lie
and not just acquiesce to a lie but to
love a lie the way that they break the
protagonist at the end of 1984 is they
force him to say that two plus two
equals five and not just to believe or
not just to say rather than two plus two
equals five but to believe that two plus
two equals five it's a profound moment
it's so basic it's so simple but it is
profound because you'll notice the
angrier and angrier and angrier the left
gets about political correctness about
about them imposing their fantasy views
on the world they just want you to
acquiesce to it and then they want you
to believe it and you don't just need to
recognize Big Brother you've got a love
big brother you got to love it and if
you don't do that if you say I just
don't think this is quite right mmm I
think what you're doing is a little bit
wrong I disagree
you won't get a civil disagreement you
will get the rage of a thousand suns and
as in 1984 they will torture you they
will torture you I mean you will lose a
lot you could lose a lot you could lose
your livelihood your reputation you can
lose friends you could lose almost
everything but only you can say that two
plus two equals five and you can also
say two plus two does not equal five
they can take everything you want there
was a story about a yeah an opera singer
who was this is not in 1984 this is
another story
an opera singer who was living in a
totalitarian country and the leader of
that country wanted to come back and
wanted her to sing for him she wouldn't
sing for him and he said I can make you
sing and what she said to him was you
can make me scream but you can't make me
sing very important these days as the
left in particular
come comes after everybody comes after
us tries to control our speech and our
thoughts makes us go along bullies us
very important only you can say two plus
two equals five and only you can refuse
to say the two plus two equals five and
keep your dignity because it might be
convenient to give in to lies and give
in to cynicism and disregard the truth
in the short run it's always convenient
in the short run but in the long run
it's all you've got thank you very much
that's the Michael Noel's show I'll see
you tomorrow in the meantime have a good
day
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director Pavel why
douse key edited by Danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by Mike core Amina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera and our
production assistant is NIC Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
if you prefer facts over feelings if you
aren't offended by the brutal truth if
you can still laugh at the nuttiness
filling our national news cycle well
tune on it into the Ben Shapiro show or
you'll get a whole lot of that and much
more we'll see you there